so austerity is over if you listen to
the Prime Minister and the Chancellor
now maybe I'm being cynical but I have
real doubts Monday's budget felt much
more like an election pitch to me one of
those budgets our government produces
when it abandons its long term strategy
instead tries to buy off the electorate
the end of austerity just doesn't ring
true given that we still have an
enormous debt our growth is one of the
slowest in Europe and our productivity
levels are pathetically low I believe
people will want to see real
improvements in public services and feel
personally richer before they are
convinced austerity is over they would
want their wages to be back up
pre-crisis levels they would want public
services to be significantly better
after years of cuts and they'd want a
much greater feeling of optimism in the
country if there is an election in the
next 12 months and I think there's a
good chance there will be despite what
the Prime Minister is saying I don't
think the voters will fall for this
[Music]
Greg cynical you know could never could
never happen for viewers who perhaps
need a little bit of a reminder of the
key measures let's quickly walk you
through what we learned in the budget
the key measures an extra 20 billion
pounds a year for the NHS over the next
five years a 2.7 billion pound
investment in the welfare reform
Universal Credit a new digital services
tax which will raise 400 million pounds
from big tech companies and income tax
cut a year ahead of schedule raising the
threshold where you start paying tax to
12,500 pounds and a 30 billion pound
package of investment in England's roads
including for fixing of the potholes so
coming back to it yes I think it
probably was it did have the feel of an
election budget interesting that just
they actually saying that it is over or
to quote him austerity is coming to an
end he said it was over and he said it's
coming so and this is a pic well she
clearly didn't he clearly didn't like
her saying that no he doesn't so
confused calm I don't know one person
who leads a country saying it is over
the other one say well no we're not
there yet but where I think there is a
real
real problem I think you're absolutely
right and you're right to focus on those
folks who are or on struggle Street down
at the lower end of the scale this extra
money for the work universal credit this
I still sense is the conservatives poll
tax this could backfire in the most
spectacular style and you track it back
to previous Chancellor George Osborne
who it would appear it would appear I
stress high-handedly decided to rob you
should take two to three billion pounds
without reference to anyone and it's
been that it started disastrously it's
been calamitous Lee introduced it's got
a terrible sniff of disaster and and in
a way poor treatment almost wicked as
well that's gonna be their problem out
of this project the other interesting
thing it seems to me in this whole thing
is you go back to an George Osmond first
weekend chance at everything was about
reducing the deficit everything we about
we do that's been abandoned this I mean
if I was born would if they were falling
for your husband sponsor they would not
have put this or get money into into
roads or into the Patna Health Service
they have time to reduce the bed but the
deficit-reduction plan is gone it's
disappear I just want to I want to agree
with you Gregg and say that actually
this looks to me like a smokescreen and
especially when you strip it away from
the protected areas of the budget let's
take a look at this graph because what
this graph does this is total
departmental spending which is set to
rise by 2.9 percent in the next few
years but if you strip out the extra
money for the National Health Service
and other protected areas which are
protected by of course law like defense
and foreign aid the unprotected
departments are set to see their budgets
cut by 2.9 percent which includes by the
way and he saw the difference in our
this includes the key areas of schools
police and prisons so we all know what's
going on with our police for example we
are unable to even charge or even
investigate stabbings and burglaries and
violent offenses we were so in some
instances cause but they're also getting
a B right seems like you know non crime
hate speech because one of the policies
that are imposed on them meanwhile real
crime is spiraling out of control our
prisons are are in a mess and of course
the schools where the teachers are
underpaid can I just add to that the
public sector pay freeze I agree with
you again I think that until the average
everyday Joe Bloggs is feeling that
difference in their pocket
it's not to try and bribe the electorate
by saying austerity is coming to an end
or has ended football's coming home
didn't come home whichever one you want
to say ultimately she tryna briber so
you remember that speech where she said
if you backed me on brexit i'll end
austerity that's the biggest bribe I've
ever heard not sorry it was an election
picture I think it was an unashamed leap
political budget to quell the mutiny in
the Tory Party there was also the
threaten that Philip Hammond can't speak
these days without a brexit threat it
was also a threat to M pacing you
sabotage the checkers deal and I will
not pay this 100 billion pound giveaway
he's actually said that so it was the
threats to people and that's not the
Chancellor's job his job brexit or no
Briggs Deal or No Deal his job is to
reassure us the public and businesses
that he will take whatever means
necessary supplies it's got a second
maybe he does everything it's always
there's always a Doomsday dividend but I
also think it has a feel that Teresa may
you know has achieved nothing in two
years of prime is that apart from
personal survival and I think this
budget is about reminding Tory voters
what for cuz no one knows what the Tory
party is for anymore doesn't have a
message anymore those things employees
well let me everything but there but
it's not good enough to say vote Tory
it's to keep jezzer out you have to have
a better reason to next time she could
come out dancing to as I Will Survive
she has now been defined by brexit when
I bring in a grab from Paul Johnson the
director of the Institute of Fiscal
Studies who actually delves deeper into
this cruel budget
yes public spending is rising over the
next four or five years for the first
time in a while but nearly all of that
money is going to the health service if
you're looking at other bits of public
services whilst the cuts have probably
stopped there's no extra money for
anything other than health which is a
real term cut and I think actually aside
from the end to austerity I think we
need to see the end to of this cruel
Tory government before people have
suffered at that and it's funny the
other day George Osborne was on another
news television show showing no remorse
whatsoever and no understanding in terms
of
how real people have suffered because of
his policies to reason me when she made
that amazing speech when she was made
p.m. she said she was gonna help the
just about managing she's gonna have the
people happy she's done none of that and
I really think what this is kind of a
pretty desperate time for the toward
employment rights um in the so called
gig economy not all no I think there is
another side and she called you can use
this as an argument in the election I
think which lets budget yes she said an
end to this Tory governor but I'm
wondering the problem is of course what
call being on the on the specs are on
the horizon is looming there so how can
there be an end to this you know you
know I'm not a Corbin fan but what I
would say is for those that are at the
bottom of society that are suffering
even more the hands of this Tory
government for them actually a Corbin
government would be a much better deal
the body yet I've got a little bit of
fact here by 20 23 24 there's the Tory
Swampert they're going to be spending 30
billion a year more than they're
spending now which is actually a pretty
good thing but but but I do what happens
in that time but a four-week yeah I know
but and Johnny Mercer you know the guy
who represents Wales from somewhere else
he he study we give he if he was he was
plumbers its way
[Laughter]
Wester bread yes it's just well but what
he's that I think makes sense he said if
he wasn't an MP
he wouldn't vote Tory now look he says
the Tories have lost their ability to
scrap what they believe in and is it
really sensible now to turn on the
spending taps at a time when we have our
national debt is 1.7 billion of course
it costs trillion one point seven nine
trillion and it's okay Plymouth sorry
Plymouth I'm sorry but Johnny Mercer is
a good man he goes to the right